sir Don McCullen is one of the most
honored photo journalists in the world
he's been knighted by Queen Elizabeth
earlier this year London's Tate Britain
held a major retrospective featuring
more than 250 of his photographs now his
workers on exhibition here in New York
Anthony Mason talked with the 84 year
old lensman who's been called the Goya
of modern war photography for Don
McCullen is not looking
it's feeling for 60 years he's been
addicted to being in the action thriving
in conflict whether it's a street
protest a street battle or a war what
are you looking for when you look
through that lens obviously the ultimate
statement that hits you straight in the
face it says what the hell is about a
photograph McCullen says has to come at
you like a high-speed train I love this
quote of yours I want my images to
contaminate your thoughts because they
contaminated mine honesty really I mean
why should I suffer on my own
many of McCullen's most striking images
are now on exhibit at the Howard
Greenberg gallery in New York City he
went to Vietnam many times in 1968 to
cover one of the longest infantry
battles of the war the brutal fight for
way his photo of a shell-shocked marine
would become one of his most famous how
many images did you take of him five
just five five I just read click click
click and the man never batted an eyelid
he also covered the war and famine in
Biafra allied unit and the conflict in
Cambodia you were almost killed in
Cambodia in 1970 yes I walked into an
ambush
he was put into this truck with the
other injured this is the moment you
almost died the man who's dying is dying
at that very moment at that picture as
you take this picture you're wounded
yeah but I many wounded in the legs I'm
not dying you
still taking pictures even though you I
think you took my mind away you know and
I thought this is an opportunity to show
ya another phase of suffering and war
McCullen's empathy came from his own
poverty this is where I grew up as a boy
in North London in his recent memoir
unreasonable behavior
McCullen admits he has a chip on his
shoulder about it
well my father died when I was 13 in
total misery and poverty and I wanted to
overcome his sort dis sorrow in our
family in 1958 he took this picture of
local gang members who were later
thought to be involved in a murder and I
took their photograph to the observer
newspaper and they said did you take
this photograph and I said I did they
said well we're gonna publish it you
remember all of these if I could only
remember the the literature I read the
way I understand photography they must
burn into you then in some way this
stuff is part of my bone marrow you were
frequently called a war photographer
which I detest actually why I suffered
terrible conscience about the way I've
chosen the last six years of my life you
know I go to Wars I see the innocent
dying you know I feel like Caesar who is
wearing uncomfortable laurels you know
war is total madness really and you're
in that war and you are part of the the
Mad Hatter's Tea Party do you ask
yourself every time you go while you're
going let's not be deceitful here first
of all the adrenaline rush was exciting
particularly when you got away with it I
know exactly what you mean in terms of
the rush you get when fear can be
exciting
he knows all forms of fear the british
author john lecarre a has said he's an
expert at it so photography kind of
duped me in some ways it led me down
places you wouldn't normally go as a
normal human being
yeah but why did I do it I don't think I
can honestly answer the question in the
90s
McCullen began to shoot winter
landscapes around his home in rural
England the
beautiful yeah I took this on my way to
a hospital where one of my children were
being born
I stopped the car and got out ran across
the fields and did this picture and then
carried on to the hospital to see my new
child they are stunning but stark there
was somebody said was it Licari that
even your landscapes are battlefields
that's right but in the fields around
dawn McCullen's home the photographer
known for war has found some peace
it was my psychiatrist it was me curing
myself by just embracing the landscape
and I must say the original journey has
not turned out the way I wanted to but
I'm quite proud of my trying on my
achievements quite proud he should be to
be a man who is about the visual
experience he has a way with words yes
he said he is amazing yes and those
images the way you can capture a moment
and bring it to someone especially in
times of war so important for those who
can't be there two of his books up in
the office yeah good for you